على وقع اشتباكات عنيفه تشهد والعاصمه
الخرطوم وشمال دارفور بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في اول يوم بعد انتهاء
الهدنه الموقعه بين الجانبين في جده دعت
الرياض واشنطن طرفي الصراع في السودان الى
اتفاق جديد لوقف اطلاق النار والى التنفيذ
بشكل فعال تمهيدا لوقف دائما للعمليات
العسكريه بحسب بيان لوزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف يمكن ان نقرا
المشهد السوداني على الصعيدين الميداني
والسياسي في ضوء اشتداد المعارك بين الجيش
والدعم السريع فور انتهاء الهده وعلى اي
نحو يمكن ان ينظر طرافات صراعي في السودان
الى دعوه الرياض و واشنطن لضروره التوصل
الى هدنه وفي اي سياق تاتي هذه الدعوه بعد
تعليق المفاوضات وما امكانيه استجابه
الطرفين المتقاتلين في السودان للدعوه
السعوديه الامريكيه في ضوء بقاء وفدي
الجيش والدعم السريع في جده رغم تعليق
المفاوضات وانتهاء الهدنه
[موسيقى]
من المنطقه الصناعيه وشارع الغابه غربيه
الخرطوم الى منطقه الجريف ثم عبورا الى ام
درمان على الضفه الغربيه من النيل الابيض
وخصوصا الجزء الجنوبي منها تصاعدت حده
الاشتباكات بقوه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
في اول يوم بعد انتهاء اخر الهدن وفي
الاسبوع الثامن من المواجهات الداميه بين
الطرفين بحسب مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم
فان المواجهات بين الجانبين المتقاتلين
شملت القصف الجوي والمدفعي الى جانب
الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه هذا
الى جانب اشتباكات في مدينه كتم بولايه
شمال دارفور تضاربت الانباء بشان ما اسفرت
عنه
وفي حين لم تعرف على وجه التحديد نتائج
المواجهات على مستوى السيطره المدنيه
للطرفين فان نتائجها على حياه المدنيين
وواقعهم الانساني بدت مرعبه بحسب الانباء
الوارده من هناك ورغم صعوبه رصد وتوثيق كل
ما يحدث فان خمسه قتله وسته وعشرين جريحا
سقطوا السبت جنوبي الخرطوم جراء سقوط
قذائف مدفعيه في احياء الازهر ومايو وذلك
بعد يومين من سقوط 18 اخرين واصابه اكثر
من مئه اثر قصف استهدف المنطقه نفسها
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
اللواء معتصم عبد القادر الحسن الخبير في
الشؤون الامنيه والاستراتيجيه من الخرطوم
ايضا ينضم الينا الباشا طباق الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن معنا
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
لشؤون افريقيا مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا معك
الباشا تطبيق من الخرطوم كيف وجدت هذا
الاشتداد الحاد للمعارك اليوم مع انتهاء
الهدنه
مرحبا بكم استاذ الكريمه والتحيه لك
ولمشاهدي قناه الجزيره والتحيه لضيفي
الكريمين من الخرطوم امين واشنطن والتحليل
الشعب السوداني الذي يعاني ويلات هذه
الحرب الحرب هي اصلا مستمره ولم تكن هنالك
استجابه واضحه كل الهدن التي مضت وفعلا
اشتدت المعارك والضربات الجويه
وقصص للمدنيين وللمواقع المدنيه
وللمستشفيات
ومن ما زاد ذلك من معاناه المواطنين
وازداد الوضع سوءا يعني في السودان
وايضا الان
الوضعي يبشر بوضع كاردي نحن الان في
الاسبوع الثامن من بدايه هذه الحرب ولن
نجد اي هدنه حقيقيه فعليه يعني استفاد
منها المواطن وخفضا امين معاناه
سوداني وكل ما يعني ازدادت ازدادت الوضع
سوءا وازداد تعقيد المشهد ويزداد المعاناه
المواطن السوداني والقصف بطيران مستمر ولم
يتوقف يوما نحن نشاهد كما ذكرت في تقرير
ان هنالك قصف للمدينين في منطقه مايو وعدد
من المناطق يعني سيدنا عدد من الضربات
الجويه تضرر منها المواطن البسيط المغلوب
على امره فهذه الحرب كل ما استمرت ذاتها
معاناه الشعب السوداني نحن الان
ماذا وراء اشتداد هذه المعارك باعتقادك
هذه المعارك يحاول الطرف يعني الجيش
تحقيق انتصار في اي موقع من المواقع التي
يستولى عليها الدعم السريع ولكن سجل تماما
والقصص بالطيران في كل ما يزداد ازداد
المعاناه المواطنين تضرر منه يعني
المواطنين لكن المعارك
والمعارك في الارض ما زالت وهات الدعم
السريع والتمسك بكل مواضيع المجال دعنا
نسال في هذا المجال اللواء معتصم عبد
القادر الحسن لواء معتصم لماذا باعتقادك
تساعدت حده المعارك بهذا الشكل اليوم
من المعارك في البدايه التي الشكل لقناه
الجزيره ولكم التحرير جميعا
اشتراك المعارك جزء هنالك ظاهره جديده
ان قوات الدعم السريع هنالك جانب منها
يريد الاستسلام ويريد الخروج من المعرفه
نتيجه لتضييق الخناع عليهم من جميع
الجوانب في ولايه الخرطوم والان
لك
اشتباكات متبادله ما بين هذه الاطراف داخل
الدعم السريع والاحداث الاخيره في مدينه
مايو نتيجه لهذه العمليه القصف الجوي
يستهدف المواقع العسكريه فقط للدعم السريع
السيارات العسكريه لان جميع المقر
والمعسكرات التي كان يستولى عليها الدعم
السريع قد تم اجلائه منها الان هم هايمون
ومحاصرون من جميع جوانب ولايه الخرطوم
وهنالك عمليات واستهداف للمدنيين كما ان
المستشفيات التي كانت هل يمكن ان تقول لنا
دواء معتصم اين هم محاصرون اين اين تتم
محاصرتهم تحديدا
السيد يقول ان الجيش يحاول السيطره ولكنه
يخفق
الجيش مسيطر تماما على كافه الاوضاع
السيطره لا تعني انك تستولى على بيوت
المدنيين او تستولى على المستشفيات او
المرافق المدنيه السيطره تعني ان تستولي
على معسكرات عسكريه الدعم السريع لا
يستولى على اي معسكر يتبع للجيش السوداني
حتى المعسكرات التي تتبع لهم والتي كانوا
موجودين فيها كقوه عسكريه الان اخذت منهم
كل هذه المعسكرات حتى الان معسكر
السفير ديفيد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون افريقيا ماذا عن قراءتك
لمسار الاحداث اليوم لصيام الاحداث
الميدانيه مع اشتداد حده المعارك
بالتزامن مع الاعلان عن انتهاء الودنه
التي اصلا لم يكن هناك التزام واسع بها
من الواضح تماما ان اي من الطرفين لا
الجيش السوداني ولا قوات الدعم السريع
لديهما اي رغبه حقيقيه لانهاء القتال في
هذه اللحظه ويبدو ان كلا الطرفين ملتزم
بحسم هذا النزاع بالقوه وكما اشير في
بدايه هذا النقاش ان الخاسر الاكبر هو
الشعب السوداني المدنيين الذين
يتعرضون للقتل والاصابه
وكلى الطرفين مستمران في القتال ويعتقدون
ان القتال يصير لصالحهم طيب بالتزامن مع
احتدام المواجهات في الخرطوم وبعد ثلاثه
ايام من قرار ميسري مفاوضات جده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده دعت
الرياض وواشن الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع الى التوصل لاتفاق وقف اطلاق نار
جديد وتنفيذه بشكل فعال تمهيدا لوقف دائما
للعمليات العسكريه بحسب بيان لوزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه واكد بيان الخارجيه
السعوديه حرص الرياض وواشنطن على استمرار
المحادثات مع وفدي التفاوض السودانيين
اضاف ان السعوديه والولايات المتحده على
استعداد لاستئناف المحادثات الرسميه
السودانيه كما اشار البيان الى ان وفدي
الجيش والدعم السريع لا يزالان موجودين في
جده رغم تعليق محادثات وانتهاء وقف اطلاق
النار وطالب بيان الخارجيه السعوديه طرفي
الصراع السوداني بالالتزام باعلان جده
وحمايه المدنيين في بلادهم
اعود اليك سفير ديفيدشن في اي سياق قرات
هذا البيان بعد يومين على تعليق على
الاعلام عن تعليق المحادثات في جده وقيام
الولايات المتحده بفرض عقوبات على طرفين
كيف نفهم هذا البيان الصادر اليوم
ان كلا من السعوديه والولايات المتحده
مخلصتان وصادقتان في رؤيه نهايه لهذا
النزاع المسلح وان يكون هناك وقفا لاطلاق
النار وتفعلان ما تستطيعان
لحث قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه
ليفعل ذلك في الحقيقه لا هذا الطرف ولا
ذاك من الطرفين المتنازعين مستعد للسعي
الى هدنه او وقف لاطلاق النار لهذا السبب
لا يحدث طبعا العقوبات واضح انها لم تؤدي
الى اقناع اي من الطرفين على وقف القتال
ولكن هل يمكن فهم مضمون هذا البيان على
انه تراجع عن خطوه تعليق المفاوضات التي
اعلن عنها قبل ايام قليله
لا اعتقد انه تغيير في الموقف اعتقد انه
ينم عن ان رغبه هو استعداد من جانب
الطرفين الوقت المتحده والسعوديه لوضع حد
لهذا النزاع لكن حتى اللحظه لم يكن هناك
تعاون طيب وايجابي لا من جهه الجيش
السوداني ولا من جانب قوات السريع لوقف
القتال البشر تطبيق الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي في الخرطوم البيان بيان الخارجيه
السعوديه يدعو الطرفين الى اتفاق على وقف
اطلاق نار جديد وتنفيذه بشكل فعال بهدف
بناء وقف دائما العمليات العسكريه
باعتقادك كيف يمكن لقوات الدعم السريع ان
تتعامل مع هكذا دعوه
اولا دعيني اشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه على هذه
الوساطه وصبرهم لرعايه هذه المفاوضات غير
المباشره بين الجيش السوداني القوات الدعم
السريع لكن اختي الكريمه هنالك مراوقه
مراوقه كبيره جدا من قبل الجيش وتعدد
الواجهات وتضارب التصريحات وعدم وحده
القرار هي اكثر تاثير كبير جدا في
الالتزام بكل الالتزامات السابقه
والمصابغه الان اذا ارادت هذه المبادره
يعني
يوجه نفس الاتهامات للقوات الدعم السريع
وبالتالي بعيدا عن كل هذه اللغه وهذه
الاجواء من الاتهامات والاتهامات
المتبادله
باعتقادك كيف يمكن ان تتعامل قوات الدعم
السريع مع هكذا دعوه الى اتفاق على وقف
اطلاق نار جديد ولكن يكون فعال هذه المره
السريع
متواجد في جده وهي ملتزمه بكل كل قراراتها
وكل التزاماتها في في سبيل تخفيف على
المواطن السوداني والخروج من هذه من هذا
المازق الذي
ادخلت فيه القوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع من اناس يريدون التمسك
بالسلطه وحكم السودان رغم ان في الشعب
السوداني
يعني تعويق المسار الديمقراطي والحكم
المدني في السودان على الوساطه الان انا
افتكر انه على الوسائط التكوين اللجنه من
من الطرفين ولجنه مراقبه من الوساطه
السعوديه الامريكيه وتكون موجوده على
وتحديد مواقع اي طرف يعني اي طرف المواقع
التي يعني يسيطر عليها وتكون هنالك مراقبه
حقيقيه ومعدانيه والرصد كل الخروقات التي
تحصل من كل الاطراف وانا افتكر ان اذا تمت
هذه يعني الخطوه تكون هنالك يعني يعني
خطوه ايجابيه وخطوه فاعله ممكن من خلالها
يعني
ايضا دعوه وردت على لسان المستشارع
السياسي لقوات الدعم السريع دعنا نسال في
ذلك اللواء معتصم عبد القادر الحسن لواء
معتصم ان كان الجيش اعلن انه يعلق مشاركته
في هذه المفاوضات والتعليق يعني خطوات
التعليق بدات بهذا الامر بخطوه من الجيش
السوداني لماذا مازال وفده موجود في جده
الوقت موجود في جده نتيجه لطلب البساطه
الوساطه طلبت من الوجود في جده انها تعلم
ان لها محاولات اخرى وان سعرها لم ينتهي
في الوصول الى اتفاق ولكن انا اعتقد ان
الجيش السوداني منتظم في الهدنه لانها
تؤدي الى مصلحه المدنيين وهذا
ما ابطل العسكريه وجعلها تاخذ كل هذا
الوقت
على
واصلحت المدنيين
وهو يلجا الى سلاح الطيران
وما زالت المجرد والاشتباكات مستمره
عمليات كلها دفاعيه
لحالات لا يجب ان يحركوا فيها ثم يريدون
ان يستولوا على العسكرات وهكذا لذلك تصلح
القوات
من الخارجيه السعوديه للطرفين
بالاتفاق على وقف اطلاق نار جديد يتم
الالتزام به هل يمكن للطرفين من دون
محادثاتك التي حدثت في السابق في جده ان
يتواصلا الى خطوه كهذه
المطلوب في البنود التي وردت في الهدنه
وفي اتفاق مبادئ الذي وقع في 11 مايو
المنصرم ان يخرج الدعم السريع من
المستشفيات ومن المرافق المدنيه ومن منازل
المواطنين ويطلق صراع المختطفين المدنيين
وما الى ذلك اذا فعل الدعم ذلك انا اعتقد
ان الحرب انتهت لان الدعم السريع
يطالب بلجنه من الطرفين لتحديد مواقع
السيطره كيف يمكن ان يتعامل الجيش مع ذلك
ليس له اي مواقع للسيطره الجيش مستعد لاي
عمل ميداني ولكن خروج الدعم السريع من
المواقع المدنيه سوف ينهي هذه الحرب لان
الدعم السريعه الان لا يمتلك اي مواقع
عسكريه هنالك رهائن في القصر الجمهوري فقط
هذه مساله مختلفه ويستطيع الجيش التعامل
معها والان هنالك حصار على كل هذه المواقع
هل تعتقد ان قوات الدعم السريع مستعده
لتلبيه هذا الطلب الخروج من المواقع
المدنيه واقف الدخول الى منازل المواطنين
وقد راينا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تداول لصور لعناصر من القوات الدعم السريع
تدخل الى المنازل
الكريم هذه كلها اختراعات سريعه المتواجد
في مواقعه
ويطالب بتكوين اللجنه لماذا يرفض يعني
الطرف الاخر اذا كان هو
الوضع تماما يقول السيد
لجنه مشتركه لتحديد مواقع يعني كل طرف
يعني تؤكد ان الدعم السريع العام مسيطره
على اكثر من 95
من مواقع من المواقع العسكريه في ولايه
الخرطوم ولكن كل الذي يقال كله
اقتراحاته ومقابره ونحن الان
نشاهدنا ما هي الانتصارات التي تحدثت وما
هو ما هي المواقع التي يسيطر عليها
اي كلام يقال غير ذلك هو كذب وابتراء يعني
مقاومه ليس الا وهي معاناه الشعب السوداني
نحن الان نرى القصر الذي يتم للمواطنين
واليوم تم استطاع الطائفه في المواطنين
وكل الكاميرات ويعني يعني الفيديوهات لذلك
نحن الان نطالب لوخفي كامل اطلاق النار
لتخطيبه الشعب السوداني والان الان الان
الظروف
هذه الاجواء سيد سفير ديفيد شين وفي ظل
هذه في ظل الاتهامات المتبادله وهذه
الاجواء من اتهام والاتهام المضاد كيف
يمكن
للميسرين ان يتوقعا من الطرفين ان يتواصل
دون محادثات
برعايه جهات دوليه ان يتوصل الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار ويتم الالتزام به
من دون التعاون شامل من القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع لا استطيع
ان احدا سيصل الى مرحله وقف لاطلاق النار
والطرفان
المتحده يحاولان تحقيق ذلك لكن ينبغي ان
تكون هناك
رغبه من الطرفين
المتحاربين
للكف عن القتال
والسماحي للمنظمات الانسانيه لكي تتدخل
وتقدم الاغاثه العاجله على الاقل في
البدايه لفتره معينه من الزمن لتصل الى
المواطن السوداني العادي لكن ليس شيء هناك
عاده عن وقف اطلاق نار شامل قد يتيح عمل
ذلك اذا ماذا تقول لنا هذه الدعوه من
الوارده في بيان الخارجيه السعوديه عن
السعوديه والولايات المتحده هذه الدعوه
للطرفين بالتواصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار في ظل هذا الجو الذي تتحدث عنه
الى ما كان يحدث في الثمانيه والاربعين
ساعه الماضيه لا يوجد امل كبير في تحقيق
النجاح لو الامر لن يتغير الا ان يصل احد
الطرفين او كلا الطرفين الى تغيير في
موقفه وان يقف عن القتال لكن لحين حدوث
ذلك لا يبدو ان هناك نتائج تبشر بخير
اشكرك من واشنطن السفير ديفيد مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا
وشكرا لضيفينا من الخرطوم الباشا طبيق
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وللواء معتصم عبد
القادر الحسن الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]